you could get the impression the british
prime minister just wanted to sign it as
quickly as possible
after putting his name to the more than
1 000 pages of complicated legal
language
boris johnson seemed upbeat
good well thank you very much everybody
and i want everybody to understand that
uh the the treaty that i've i've just
signed is
is not the end it is it is a new
beginning
and i think the beginning of what will
be a wonderful relationship between
the uk and our friends and partners in
the european union
i'd like you to welcome uh with us today
in number 10.
uh here it is folks this is it uh
and i know the question you all be
asking yourselves is
is have i read it the answer is yes
and it's an excellent deal for this
country
to get their heads around a document
like this members of parliament would
usually require months
but the british lower house pushed it
through in just half a day
521 only 73 voted against the deal
which officially puts an end to years of
brexit negotiations
we're going to become a friendly
neighbor the best friend
and ally the eu could have
working hand in glove whenever our
values
and interests coincide while fulfilling
the sovereign wish of the british people
to live under their own laws but it
comes at a price
mps from northern ireland and scotland
voiced their concerns that the unity of
the united kingdom
was now under threat the opposition
labour party agreed to the deal
largely because it didn't have a choice
a thin deal
is better than no deal and not
implementing
this deal would mean immediate tariffs
and quotas with the eu
which will push up prices and drive
businesses to the wall
it'll mean huge gaps in security
eu leaders put their name to the deal
earlier on wednesday
it was then flown by the royal air force
to britain to be signed
but with many aspects of the deal not
yet final
the saga is not over yet
let's have a look at some of the changes
that come into force when
britain exits the eu customs union and
single market
free movement of people ends british and
eu citizens will have to apply for a
visa if they want to work
in each other's territory or live there
for longer than 90 days
uk eu trade in goods uh britain wanted
tariff and free quota access to the
single market
and it got it but there is now a
mechanism where terrorists could be
imposed
by the eu in the future if the uk
diverges
from standards
customs border in the irish
sea with northern ireland so northern
ireland remains part of the eu's single
market and customs union
so goods and animals entering there from
the rest of the uk
will be subject to checks and paperwork
and our correspondent in london berger
mars has more
on what exactly the post-brexit deal
means for the uk
boris johnson has signed the brexit deal
that he has reached with the eu
and parliament had its scrutiny however
many critics
of this uh process in parliament are
saying that
practically it's not enough so the mps
only had a few hours to debate
this really complex agreement with the
european union and
given the fact that the brexiteers had
always promised that brexit was all
about taking back control and giving
control to the uk parliament
many parliamentarians were very
frustrated that they only had a few
hours
to look into this agreement however the
deal is done and boris johnson obviously
is celebrating the fact that he
accomplished taking the uk out of the
european union that
there is more sovereignty free of for
example the european court of justice
critics are saying that he is not clear
about the trade-offs
that he's not explaining to the country
that yes there is more sovereignty
but economically there are trade-offs
and even though there is a deal a trade
deal with the eu
that there will be extra trade barriers
for example for manufacturers there'll
be much more paperwork
when they want to deal with the european
customers or clients and that boris
johnson
and his brexiteers have never made that
clear and obviously on a day like this
they are not talking about it either and
i'm now joined by quinton peel he's
associate fellow for the with the
european program
uh at chattanooga he's joining us from
london good to see you quinton so
do british people think they got a good
deal
no they don't or they don't appear to
the
latest opinion poll that i've seen says
that only 17
of the british people think it's a good
deal something like
21 think it's a bad deal and
father most people either think they
don't
know or they just don't care
i think there is a real exhaustion about
this whole process
with the british people and even though
they don't think it's a good deal
rather more than half of them wanted it
to be approved nonetheless
quentin the prime minister boris johnson
says that the uk
will remain a partner with the eu uh
it's it's it's best ally i think he said
will be the best of friends at some
point
what kind of relationship is this going
to be
i think it's going to be pretty bumpy at
least for the beginning until
until this whole thing settles down um
it's been
a fairly poisonous negotiating process
for the last nine months
um and before that most of the people in
boris johnson's government
have a track record of saying very rude
things
about the european union so i don't
think it is going to be easy
there's an awful lot that remains still
to be done
this deal deals with goods trade and
says
okay they'll be tariff and quota free
there's practically nothing in there
about services trade which is far more
important to britain
so there's an enormous amount actually
still to be organized
so brexit led to a growing independence
movement
in scotland how concerned are people in
britain about this
i think that's going to become the big
issue now
is just will the united kingdom hold
together as a union
having left the european union the
scottish
people voted very clearly
well over 60 percent to remain in the
european union
and now the scottish national party
which voted
absolutely clearly yesterday against
this deal
they're going to win i'm pretty certain
the next elections in scotland and
demand
another referendum boris johnson's going
to try and resist it
so that's one pressure on the union but
the other one is in northern ireland
because as you said in your introduction
there's going to be
a new effective border between northern
ireland and the rest of britain
northern ireland is in future going to
be in many ways
closer to the republic of ireland than
it is
to the rest of the united kingdom and
that i think is going to raise a lot of
new tensions there as well all right
that's quentin pale
speaking for chatham house in london
thank you